hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan here and today we
are going to discuss about how to deal
with the tromposky attack
uh well trump overski attack is gaining
a popularity in last 10 to 20 years and
the popularity is still increasing the
simple reason is
the theory section is very very easy to
learn and not only that on top of that
some ims and gm's have recommended uh
this opening as is in their opening
repluta
and
theory is very very easy to learn it
does not require much efforts and
especially you do not need to go into
the deep oceans like in queens gambit
so
that attracts many club players and
people are employing as a weapon in
tournaments
uh
so in today's lecture we are going to
deal how to deal with this transfer ski
attack and uh
i learned this uh this system uh from
one of my opponent uh to give you a
brief history a few months back i played
my first free day open rated tournament
and uh as
recommended by one of the iem uh i was
like you know impressed by this line i
and i have employed this line in that
tournament
and i was getting a good success i
beated two 1900 plus guy
and i draw against two one three nine so
people were noticing me and they were
looking at my school [ __ ]
and uh just after this game uh i came to
know that my opponent specially
designed the system
against me against pg5 and
with the help of fritz
and the move orders are so accurate as
you as you know it's is
analyzed by fritz so it can be accurate
so
it's i thought it's one of the very good
system against the trompowsky so
let me go into uh
to this line so first of all white plays
d4
and
here there is one recommendation from me
if you're playing d5 you do not need to
think beyond but if you're playing
knight f6 and you know that your
opponent is going to play bg5
uh i recommend you should play d5 and
just change the attack just for that
game
because against d5 uh trumpowski is not
that effective as it is against knight
f6 so d5 is uh less effective and we are
going to see in this game why why it's
such a case
okay so i played bg5 and here first he
played h6
so driving my bishop okay it's a normal
theory of the trumpos bishop goes back
and uh
here he played c5 now c5 uh required
some comments
uh
in in the reprotha people
gm ims and strong players they they have
mentioned the c5 and they have mentioned
that c5 is not a good move from black
side
and even some of them are saying that
it's a blunder by a second or third move
by black
well
if
white is going to capture that c pawn as
they have suggested
i don't think so it's right uh like you
know uh in fact i think reverse is true
white is making a blunder at third move
and you are going to see why because
under 2000 plus players is going to be
fine you having lots of good traps
working on them but over 2000 players
it's not the case
reason behind they are recommending this
move d cross c5 because uh
there are many
cheap traps available and
that's why it attracts lots of club
players so before going into our game
let's see one of the cutest cutest trap
in the trompowsky so
this is like d cross we are going
leading with d cross c5
and now if black is not aware of few of
the traps black might try this move
queen a5 plus
and now as you can see it's giving a
check and try to regain the pawn
but doing in that process uh he has to
deal with this move
knight c3 and now he will think oh oh if
i'm gaining that pawn i'll lose another
point so i need to defend that pawn
first right so he he played e6
and now i will renew the threat by
playing e4
so black third okay i'll capture this
pawn and then later on i will again gain
this pawn and then i will have a nice
game from
but it's not a case because now white
has this shocking move
and as you can see from the arrows that
uh if the black capture that pawn at
then it will be the black king will be
mated
so especially five minutes three minutes
you probably win a quick games like this
but in tournaments if you get us this
situation most likely you open and going
to play this move queen c7 uh dealing
with the mid thread
and now
uh another good move away so gaining
more time on the queen
and only way to get out of this knight
attack and saving the mate is queen d7
and here strangely but strongly enough
uh white will capture the screen
and please note that any capture by
bishop of the knight leads to the mid by
the knight shaq so black force pulley
has to capture with this king
and now white will do a castle and again
checking the king
now king can only go to the c6 square
because if it goes to the e8 square it
will be checkmated by uh rook again
rook to d8 so king has to move up c6 and
the beauty about this line is everything
is very very forceful uh black cannot
deviate any other moves so up to this
point it's everything is forceful and
now white has another good move which is
knight to d6 and now you can see it's
exerting pressures on f7 and c8
and if your opponent opponent is not
strong and he does not calculate well
here and if it foolishly take this
knight then it will leads the leads to
the mate in two so now you can find it
it's very easy so first of all group
chat and as you can see it's only one
move [ __ ] king goes there and
you can find it yep it's a bishop check
and made
so that is one of the cute trap and
there are many more like this and that
attracts a whole bunch of players to go
into this line
but the problem is
it's not going to work at the higher
higher uh
against the higher rated players
especially people over 2000 plus
and uh i'm going to demonstrate uh why
it's such a case so here when i played d
cross c5 as i as i stated earlier that
my opponent has prepared this line
especially against me
so uh if you do not have any systems
again trumpowski just try this line and
you'll be amazed the the good position
you are getting so okay so he played
here g5
so driving my bishop okay bishop has
only one square bishop g3
at this point it's not to worry because
it's the main theory of the trumporski
uh
and now he played strongbow he played
bishop g7 now you can see the first
drawback of d cross c5 so it's
immediately lying at that b2 square
which i need to protect okay here i i do
not want to play knight c3 because i
thought somewhere down the line probably
he will if he wishes he can capture my
knight
and then it can [ __ ] my pawn so i
played c3 uh dealing with that threat
and now he played knight a6
now not only he he tried to regain his
spawn
but if i foolishly played b4 as i
suggest as i shown by there over here
over here
then
it can actually capture that b pawn as
well because as you can see my c pawn is
spin so i cannot capture by night
otherwise my rook will be fall
so that's why
i cannot hold on to my pawn in a nice
way so i thought okay let me give up
that one
try to concentrate on my development
but
like by the way that's what the chess
theory suggested you do not need to be
greedy you just concentrate on your
dialogue developing side so i played e3
uh developing my another bishop
and he captured back and now you can see
that knight is exerting more pressures
on d3 and e4 squares
and uh probably bishop f5 will be an
agenda
so i thought uh if the bishop f5 has
been allowed that will be really really
risky position for me so that's why i
played queen c2 stopping any bishop f5
and now he played knight f6
and here uh i got somewhat nervous here
i thought uh maybe those knights can
jump onto the e4 square
and it's not a pleasant position for me
so i played my f first mistake in the
game i played f3
and i think it's very very premature
because now you can see that e pawn
is very very weak and my opponent ex
exploit this very magnifice
magnificently in the game
so here
he played bishop d7
and as you can see by the arrows uh
bishop or knight can come any time to
the a4 square
so
i played a4 which i still think it's not
a bad move because as the trumpos case
here is resisted you go on to the king
side castling and then you throw your
queen side pawns up to the board and if
i'm playing a a4 right now maybe in the
future it will help for my queen side
attack so it's not a tell a bad move
but still the drawback is i'm not
developing still any of my pcs
and here he comes with another good move
see that's the good sign of the player
he's is disturbing your plans and keep
developing keep keep creating the
threats to you and every now and then
i have to forget about my development
and i have to worry about his threats so
now he come up with another threat so
now he's renewed the thread of bishop f5
so i have to deal with it and uh after a
long thinking i come up with this move
which is i think still think it's a nice
move uh bishop uh
p5 so stopping any bishop movement and
now he castle so now he's indeed
threatening bishop f5 so i have to
capture this bishop
and here with my surprise he took back
within this night and i thought
uh what's what is going on i said okay
not a problem
but you'll see the
good side of this night move
in the later section
okay so i thought okay it's now time to
develop my pieces so i played knight e2
and he played e5
i brought my other knight into the game
so knight d2
and here he played rook e8 and now i
castle
and when the both side castle that's the
time you have to stop and just look at
the board and analyze what exactly
happening and as you can see over here
d cross c5 earlier in the game
cost me very very dearly over here you
can see those pawns
uh
i mean this and this phone
see how many squares they are
controlling in the center and look at my
these three pieces over here queen and
two knights so passive look at my small
pawns over here they are they are not
exerting any pressures in the center and
uh
black is already so much strong and
white is very very passive in this
position and i was very depressed at
this point i thought i thought uh oh my
god uh
there's some horribly goes wrong
in this opening
and i was wondering why this is
happening and
at the time i didn't realize because i
had to think a lot so
let's see how the game progressed so
here he played
as i suggested as i said said that good
players always come with their own
threats and stopping your plans so he
played queen c5 attacking my
e pawn so i have to defend again
so i played
bishop f2 which is again a big mistake
see once you're getting passive and you
do not like your position you tend to
make this kind of errors and that that
was such a case in in mice in this kind
of in this kind of games for me
so i played bishop f2
uh and
he played of course
e4 which is a very good move and
stopping any point
moving my phone moving
so
i thought okay let me kick this queen
and king queen goes back to see it
and then i played another bad move i
played rook to d8
completely ignoring black's this threat
and look at that monster knight
it can jump to c4 it can jump to d3 and
not only that it's exciting more
pressures on f3 and i'm completely
helpless to stop that
and here i thought probably half an hour
and i didn't find the right move
and at the end i've come up with another
blunder more i played bishop g3
which is
uh
i thought
it's okay mo but
if you can pause the video over here and
find a very good continuation which
probably
give great advantage to the black
okay my i thought i thought maybe he
will capture f3 or he will play maybe
play knight d3 but he played knight c4
attacking the pawn on e3 for the family
fork
so
i have to defend that so i played queen
back to c1
and then he played this wonderful move
e cross f3 and now you can see
two pieces are joining at e3 and
i have to forcefully capture with the
root to give a support and then you can
see it yep
it's g5
sorry g4 and now my root is helpless my
root has to move and then that pawn will
be fall and if that pawn will be fall my
whole game will be phone full very very
quickly so at this point i thought okay
enough is enough i have defend enough my
position it's time to attack it's time
to do counter attack otherwise i will be
like you know
get down very very easily so i thought
okay it's time to do exchange sacrifice
so i exchanged my rook with the knight
so he captured with the bishop then i
play bishop f4
attacking the ash pawn so he draw back
his bishop and then i capture this pawn
and here i thought okay i done extreme
sacrifice good i'm back in the game my
pcs are more active now and i can look
forward for some kind of attack
attacking
style
but it's just an illusion you know when
you
open with a bad opening uh you don't
hope for more unless and until your
opponents make errors which generally
people beyond 2000 does not make it
and here he played very very good moves
so he first of all he played queen moves
over here attacking my room so my rook i
slide my rook across to attack his pawn
so he defended
and now
i played attacking another attacking
justice which is knight to d4 attacking
his queen so queen slide across to g6
and uh
here i made another error i play king f2
i i'm not sure right now why i played
that move because probably i thought
that i should over protect that e3 pawn
which is very very vulnerable
and probably stopping any g3 but it's
all together very weak move and i'm just
exploiting my king so here he played
rook to d8 and look at the black's
position it's so good and look at that
knight it's so wonderfully placed
uh
i i was fed up with that knight uh like
you know power so i thought it's time to
remove this knight so i played knight d2
tried to eliminate that knight to
challenge that knight
and he played another good one he played
in height to
b5 and is now threatening queen and a
king four
so i have no choice to capture that
knight and he captured back with the
bishop and now he's introducing another
thread so bishop to h2
so i defended with knight
f1
okay um only thing i'm doing is
defending in this game i'm not doing any
kind of attacks so i'm still extending
down i'm still defending
and uh
here it comes another good move rook b6
so planning is rook to swing across to
f6 give me a check and somewhere down
the line rukan
uh comes to f2
so
i thought okay uh the situation needs
some desperate measures so i try to do
some queen trades so i thought if the
queen will be exchanged then it will be
probably i'll hang on to the end game
but here he refuted that first of all
he'd give the check so my king has to
move and then he played this move so
again renewing the threat on h2 so i
have defended
with this move g3 and now he plays queen
here
and now he's aiming for that juicy g2
square
so here again i got confused i was i
have really less time on the clock and
after some thinking i come out with this
move knight d2
stopping any queen traits but
that leads
to my h pawn is gone to the death
so my etch pen arch pawns leave the
board
with the check so my king goes up
and now here he played this move rook f2
as i suggested earlier that group some
somewhere down the light will come
straight and here it comes
here i play desperately looking for
counter play
so i play queen to
d1 attacking his g4 pawn
and
here my opponent comes with a brilliant
move
he takes this one
and the first glance i thought oh he
might be blunder because i can check him
and then can regain the bishop but then
i realized that oh my god bishop can
come back and there is no time for
capturing the g4
so
and here i thought even if i capture
this bishop
he can capture my g pawn and then his h
and g point will run down the board and
it's very very horrible position already
for the wire so i thought okay more
secondary it's time for more sacrificing
so i thought this line i captured this i
know his bishop going to come back so as
it as he did and then i played this move
i thought i am gaining time on the rook
and same time i can give a check and
attack his rook and i maybe get some
count to play down
down the his you know
back rank
but he comes with another good move
because you know good players have this
kind of tendency they know the scenario
and they will deal with very elegantly
so he played this move he's just
captured my knight
and here i was very very desperate i
should resign over here but i thought i
just carried out you know i was
i was in a big shock there
so he kept i captured with the king then
he threw over this checks so my king was
dancing on the board like this
and he give a check so i block with my
pawn and he comes off this with this
move so now he's aiming for
this square
d3
but here phil suggested i should give a
check to the king and when kings goes up
then you should exchange the queen still
it's it's not good for white because
it's a piece down nothing to play but uh
it will be better than the whatever
happened in the game so i played another
hilarious move which is e4
and my opponent finished my install so
my opponent give me a check it goes over
here you check
and then you give a check and this is a
checkmate
so
though there are few things which you
can learn from this game first thing is
if you do not have any systems again
trumpowski uh the way my opponent played
you should try in your own game and you
will be amazed by the position you will
get
if not winning then but you will
probably at least get a good position
out of any strong players
second thing is if you are trump or ski
player please avoid d cross c5 because
it might work for a lower rated player
but against higher rated they will
bambooze you like this
and the last thing which is very very
important concept is if you playing any
tournaments if you prepared one line if
you're getting a good success
make sure you have another openings or
another systems in your stock because
sometimes people
if you are getting success they will
know what you are going to play and they
prepare
with the help of software like fritz or
any good softwares and they will
demolish you like this
so those are the important lessons i
have learned in a hard way but i have
make your life easier so you will be
gaining this kind of knowledge
okay best of luck for your games in the
future against trumporski and i'll meet
you soon bye